who here is already pro basketball
player mr doncic they're only seven you
are behind children i am ancient 23 year
old i've had it all figured out for
decades plus
see i know this it's magic poor dude
[Music]
welcome to the arena outside of space
and time where we have the wonder boy
the matador 22 luca doncic
versus 2008 paul pierce i don't think so
give me a real challenge i am hallelujah
i am luca magic have it your way kid
your challenger will be multiple
championship winnings finals in league
mvp 1987
irvine magic johnson
it's an incredible honor to be with you
floating balls of light tonight
he smiled and oh he smiled hey ivan
drago is this rich no not real nba
oh cocky huh
[Music]
like watching a tuna can do ballet
ladies and gentlemen
showtime
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry magic man not my tempo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a white boy who could play
[Applause]
larry
i know that slow old mad game anywhere i
have not seen that look since the 1987
lakers celtics finals
nice try with that terrible euro
disguise you're dumb
i'm from obana it's it's a big city
[Applause]
hey let's do this again when you're
grown how do you like that schooling kid
is it possible i do not have it all
figured out in my four nba seasons maybe
there is hope for you children begin
okay you gotta catch that
[Music]
okay so crypto is a title it'll never
catch on what did you say that about a
three-point line no one's gonna be able
to make that look how far it is from the
hoop
i stand by that one ruin the game ftx
don't miss out on the next big thing